reading in foreign language and I only
know reading okay so that's what we'll
leave it that's what we're going to be
talking about today because I'm you know
reading is something that I found to be
a very powerful tool for you know
improving my vocabulary
capacity to express myself etc etc in
foreign languages and I've had a number
of conversations with Luper about this
and I thought be great to talk about it
on camera and you know some of you may
know that I've been living in Spain for
approximately one year now and one of
the things that was a bit surprising to
me when I came is that you know being in
the country and being around native
speakers because it's not enough to
really develop that that finesse in you
know the way you express yourself and I
remember speaking to lucre about this
and he said David you need to read the
hidden need to read you know so I
thought that you know we would put the
advice that just gave to me on camera so
it looka why is it important to read why
is reading important for a language okay
so first of all let's let's let's talk
about reading in general
I would say reading basic connect the
dots in general when people say well
this water I'm not fond of I think that
wrote smart more or less but people read
more you can tell when a person needs
more
more than you or weeds a lot because
they have
you know vision
so first all reading your own name my
first piece of advice would be read
aloud eight years old a native before
talking about
the second piece of advice would be that
the reason why reading is so important
is because you will find words you know
what you said something interesting
what did I say it's not about all I said
I said it's not about the words on the
page or the ideas behind the words
attack so the words represent and so you
tend to learn words through and thanks
to ideas so you read you get in contact
with ideas and you learn the words of
suppose
I never really focused on running words
like I was more the secret is get a
bulky wife and the more interesting the
more the ideas are interesting and the
more of the words that represent them
are going to stick to your brain
another very important thing is that as
you said before living in the constant
have as interesting conversations is
going to allow you to more
first of all first of levels
it will help you develop fluency with a
passive interactive reading is our step
when we talk about c1
they'd like
I believe that you can be a fluent
speaker without necessarily having to
read books because you can you can do
that through car newspapers but the
package
but if you want to reach a knuckle level
some say superior
you have to read a lot I've noticed that
people speak a language well or they
give the impression seeing 11 12 and
they don't read if you go deeper you
will find out that there are some holes
now you don't have to go around and
check there's people to c1 c2 but it one
of the main conditions is true in our
otherwise you will not get down and
really hooker connect - are you said you
know otherwise you will not get there
and you know I think that there will be
a lot of people listen saying why does
look you're talking about you will not
get the you know let's look a little bit
about this you know do you think that
it's you think that it's absolutely
necessary to read or to reach those high
levels or is it most people have to do
it to reach those I think that most
people have to do wise you have an
extraordinary memory
television etc it's not just about words
it makes you think
you speed up the process of thinking
then gourds are trying to complicate you
or
to express yourself better in general
you know expressing yourself better
doesn't necessarily apply they have to
use very difficult words
simplicity is key but is it the way the
words are combined together how you
compile exactly work it's a way you
combine words to form cards first you
have black dots and you transform them
any words and eating is very healthy if
I think about the language they speak
best it's not
it's not a cases the fact that I read a
lot of books
just read a lot and all sorts of things
are not just saying like extensive
reading intensive
it's about reading everything
then only you know understandingly words
I don't
and this is where the human side of it
has to come into it where you you read
and then you find ways to hope these new
words and ideas into exactly it's a
combination it's like reading on one
hand thank you
words and expressions in real
conversation it makes a huge difference
and so one thing that we want to sort of
address I want to I want to make sure
that everyone gets the idea here is
maybe some maybe we can talk about some
specific strategies for reading should
we stop when we don't know what a tree
just looked at my latest gaps but what
do you do how do you approach reading
and I'm on their side Anna so we need to
give it over now there are different
ways of reading you can for example a
mark for us but don't stop every time
- be divided into smaller shorter
reading sessions when you help with
pages or stop resent you
if we're dictionaries look at that
they're not useful anymore we have to
have to make the understanding word has
to be fast then so and it is fast
because we work there you can use an
online dictionary but then digesting the
work is
because people tend to see well you know
I mark that word over paper it doesn't
they have to find ways to digest and
obviously there are some useful
techniques to digest words but forced
understanding words like greeting
session
couple of pages you stop every two pages
mark all the words while you're reading
without stopping use a highlighter
whatever
and then you look up all the words
worth five minutes
and you can even write some examples not
just about the meaning
you can write it on the book
so you're personalizing the book like
making it yours they're adding something
like writing books you to make a list
you can use a piece of paper and you can
buy the dates when you started
and things like that yeah and so let's
go one more thing I wanna mention is you
know selecting you know the books that
you select you know because my boss I've
had the experience and I'm sure many
many many learners watching this and
they have had the experience of you know
selecting a book that is you know very
difficult and thinking should it be this
difficult should I continue or selecting
the book that's very easy and feeling as
though that is excuse me feeling as
though is it's not challenging so you
know do you have anything to say about
selecting a book burn him yeah it
depends on the level if you have an
intermediate level I would say stick to
articles or the boss
this is called intensive reading try to
on the Internet
on articles that have for example
translation you know
so that you make sure that you
understand the text even if it's
difficult it's short because if you take
if you start reading a book which is
very long and very complicate your not
going to read possibly you guys
I don't like this but if you train on
smaller pieces of information and you do
possibly for six months then you're
ready to jump on
and the important thing is not the
difficulty dust counter workout
is whether that book is interesting or
not that book is not interesting even if
they're not gonna leave
book is very interesting
if it's been and it's very difficult
take a step by step how will pages a day
three pages a day that he'll step off
it's a progressive process so they range
dirty as always and even it did happen
to me that when I was twelve I I decided
to read it's at least an angle it's very
complicated an intermediate level not
even intermediate and the owner like the
guy told me
to complication I want to read every
would like it because I'd watch the
movie
I'm very interesting and I started
reading it day by day three four pages
at a market all the lords and
helps usually because I said I can be
500-page
I can I can
once you've done it you know like a way
once you know you can do it once you've
got it and you know
fantastic okay so that's what we have to
say today about reading in a foreign
language if you want to find out more
about you know making language part of
your life and ways that you can you know
reach the high levels of language make
sure you listen to the podcast that I
recorded with Luka Lampanelli for the
languages culture podcast you know go to
languages culture comm and you get to
find out lots of great information
that's going to help you on your
language journey thank you for watching
Wow